uh eight player multiplayer um that just
works but uh
once again it was it was tricky to get
that going so with
multiplayer are there going to be any
changes any differences in there from
pvp to trading to how
players interact you know units blocking
each other and i mean
all sorts of stuff so with multiplayer
uh we want to keep all the features
you've known and loved there so pvp will
still be there
down to like opening the party window
and engaging hostility
um trading is still going to function
the same as you know
you know you can go into games trade
items or talk in chat channels and
things like that
areas of improvement though like i said
going back to my mentioning of
reimagining a lot of the ui
um improvements to the balance lobby um
so
we're trying to look at some things like
improving uh like how you browse
uh server games like so when you're
looking at a game to join
in typing passwords and things like that
that's the kind of area we're trying to
see how we could smooth out in ways like
um making sure you can browse uh normal
games nightmare games and
hell games even though you've graduated
to the higher difficulty
i'm sure you've known that there's
nothing nothing worse than
accidentally killing bail and nightmare
when you're trying to do nightmare bail
runs and you're like
i can't find any of the games anymore
for nightmare bail runs
but you can if you log into a separate
character right you go to a separate
character and then look at
our logic right we want it we want we
since there are workarounds there
that that made it easier for us to make
the decision of allowing some of those
things
um another change is also looking into
uh reducing ladder seasons overall so
right now ladder seasons in diablo 2 are
six months
and we're looking at reducing that as
well to help
uh have more engagement um and and
kind of drive more incentives too you
know six months is a long time
um and we're looking into like if we
make it shorter we could probably
have greater beats throughout the year
as well as
seeing people strive harder for getting
like that to that level 99 right
so is there going to be any
reward change on that or will it just
simply be
you know the same standard you get to 99
you're
99 on that leaderboard and i mean that's
a giant reward in itself
but i don't know if there's any uh other
piece go up on the
battlenet website or something we're not
looking into adding
any thing beyond what the game really
did but in some ways there
there will be some things that kind of
come out of because of what we change
so we have the latter the leader board
right where you can see
each class going to level 99. there are
easier ways to filter through that
um and we're also looking into
saving that right so you can always look
back to previous
uh seasons as well so in a way we're
creating that kind of legacy now
that has kind of been dropped from the
past so that's that's one advantage is
kind of your names could be there in the
legacy to look in the past
i mean i think that would be cool enough
just anything to
keep it there as like uh forever like
this was season one season two you know
like that's when i got my name because i
know a lot of people like to go and
reflect kind of on their old characters
and pushes and
stuff like that character exploration
will not be a thing anymore by the way
due to modern battle net integrations we
do not have to you will not have to
worry about refreshing your character so
they will stay with you
awesome um will there be anything
different with like
character names then if that's the case
oh
yeah so this is one that we talked about
for a very very long time so
uh because we are moving to global
servers
and we have um cross progression
uh we will allow duplicate names
um because with everyone being in the
same thing across all consoles and all
platforms and other things like that you
would very quickly bump into duplicates
um like day one and so we are allowing
duplicate names however they will also
be
um appended with your your gamer tag or
your battlenet id
or things like that so that you are
still unique
um but this also allows us to get for
people to play the game quicker
because we can give you we can autofill
in your name um other things like that
rob touched on a little bit but another
mention there was
going to global servers as well so
this is a new thing we're doing where
the concept of u.s
west u.s east asia regions um
and eu are no longer going to be a thing
in terms of like um being on separated
servers so now
for the push for a global uh play
with with diablo 2 you can now be able
to join
across people around the world i think
that's a fantastic change that's always
been one of the like saddest parts is
like
they're on eu and i'm on you know us
east and then my other friend's on us
west and it's like
how do we get us all together you know
like okay somebody has to make a
sacrifice there
um and so this is that seems like a
really positive change